11 kriege gibt es heute
weltweit irak oder syrien sind nicht
weiter weg von hier als schweden und
dennoch empfinden wir diese bilder
unendlich weit entfernt
fotografen konfrontieren uns mit diesen
bildern fotografen die christoph bangert
kriegsbilder wie diese zeigen wir andere
nicht denn die medien wollen die würde
der opfer nicht verletzen
ihr publikum nicht schockiert wohl aber
aufklären beschönigen wir den krieg
hören wir zu brutale bilder nicht zeigen
aus diesem dilemma heraus entstand das
buch war polen christoph bangert lebten
der schweiz auch für dieses land hat er
seine bilder gemacht ein land wo die
zeugen des letzten krieges heute von
moos überwuchert sind
es ist ein kleines buch geworden ist war
mir sehr wichtig dass es klein ist das
buch man kann es fast nur alleine
ansehen und das macht man nicht in der
gruppe und es entsteht ein verhältnis
zwischen mir dem autoren und fotografen
und den betrachter und das geht von
einer person zu anderen das ist sehr
direkt und sehr persönlich sie ist also
in dem sinne keine zurschaustellung der
arbeit sondern fast eine kommunikation
eine unterhaltung zwischen mir und den
betrachter
eine unterhaltung die peinigt sie zwingt
den betrachter sich den krieg zu stellen
einige fotos hin zu grausam dass wir sie
ihnen nicht zeigen
fernsehsender erhalten kriegsbildern im
stundentakt
sie zeigen auch das was nach dem
beschuss passiert alles das was die
tagesschau und zehn verziehen
aussortieren was mir täglich inneren
bildern
das sprengt teilweise verstellt ist
derart brutal das muss hier zeigen
würden wir sind immer ich meine dilemma
die wir dürfen nicht mehr band nicht auf
der 1.000 bilder von extrem und gewalt
zeigen darf unsere zuschauer schockiert
standards siebten informationsauftrag
wir dürfen die das geschehen ins bild
von der realität zeigen und in dem
dilemma stecken und in jeder tag zum
beispiel tagesschau 30 dezember 2006 die
hinrichtung des iranischen diktator
saddam hussein
dafür genügt der strang und das bild des
toten den moment seines todes selbst
zeigt die tagesshow nicht ungekürzt
zeigt das buch nordhorn die bilder von
tod und gewalt
das sind sehr starke bilder aber fürs
fernsehen wäre ganz viele vor deiner
bilder nicht geeignet die bilder
überhaupt nicht er hat wie wir sie für
dieses medium ablehnen oder aber so in
buchform oder als fotografie war glück
wissen dass siri land weil sie noch
aktiv könnten die in dasburg kompletter
so finde das gut weil wir zehn 2 k
manche von christof babatz fotos fanden
ihren zweck schon in den großen
magazinen und tageszeitungen dieser welt
viele bilder wollten aber auch seine
auftraggeber nicht türken fotos die den
ganzen krieg zeigen nichts beschönigen
nichts weglassen
mit dem buch laut christoph bannert das
richtige medium gefunden zu haben
kontext ist das wichtigste wie zeige ich
die bilder gewisse bilder in die bucht
kann man nicht vorne auf einer
zeitungsseite drucken wenn ja auch nicht
hin hier als medienschaffenden müssen
wege finden diese bilder zu
veröffentlichen
ich will dass diese diskussion auch
immer wieder und ständig stattfindet wie
können wir so solchem material zeigen in
einem kontext der der sinnvoll ist und
der über den schock den jeder erfährt
wenn er solche bilder ansieht weit
hinausgeht das kleine intime buch ist
ein gutes medium für diese bilder
sein erfolg zeigt dass erstaunlich viele
leser den mut aufbringen den krieg nah
an sich heranzulassen
auch hier wo seit langem gras wächst
über den panzer stehen